près d'un demi million de contamination
par jour c'est le contexte qui entourait
le nouveau conseil de défense présidée
par emmanuel macron ce matin ce soir
jean castex et olivier ferrand tiendront
une conférence de presse ils dévoileront
le calendrier de levée des restrictions
le gouvernement qui se montre optimiste
alors que le pass pourraient entrer en
vigueur dès ce week end ont fait le
point avec notre reporter nadège
abderrazak devant l'elysée
cette déclaration de gabriella talent a
un goût de campagne électorale elle a
plutôt ressemblé à un discours de
défense du quinquennat macron la porte
parole du gouvernement a défendu bec et
ongles la politique mise en place par
l'exécutif il a affirmé que la situation
économique du pays s'est améliorée au
cours des cinq dernières années et que
les français regardent je cite l'avenir
avec beaucoup d'optimisme
nous avons asie un million de nouveaux
emplois ont été créés depuis 2017 nous
avons enfin recommencer à créer des
emplois industriels est désormais la
france est un pays où l'on relocalise
nous avons fait des jeunes aussi notre
priorité et 700 mille contrats
d'apprentissage ont été signés rien
qu'en 2021 alors en ce qui concerne la
crise sanitaire gabriela talent reste
sur la ligne de conduite du gouvernement
si la catastrophe dit il a été évitée en
france c'est grâce aux vaccins et aux
passes sanitaire en aucun cas il n'a
privilégié une quelconque baisse de la
dangerosité avec ce variant omicron par
rapport à ses prédécesseurs qui aurait
joué un rôle majeur sur l'amélioration
de la situation sanitaire qu'abriel
attal a annoncé une conférence de presse
conjointe de jean castex et d'oliviers
et verront ce soir à 19 heures et les
deux hommes devraient annoncer un
calendrier détaillé pour la levée
progressive des mesures de restriction
qu'abriel attal n'a rien laissé paraître
à ce sujet excepté que ce calendrier
pourrait concerner les jauges lors de
grands événements une réduction du
télétravail ou encore une possible
prochaine réouverture des discothèques
l'arrivée du pass vaccinale permettra
aussi probablement d'assouplir
un nombre de mesures parce que c'est un
outil nouveau dont nous disposons qui
permet de renforcer la sécurité dans un
certain nombre de lieux et donc c'est
dans ce contexte là que le premier
ministre avec olivier ferrand vont
annoncer ce soir un calendrier précis
des paliers d'allègement des mesures qui
restent aujourd'hui en vigueur dans
notre pays pour donner des perspectives
aux français qui les attendent
évidemment on en saura plus en ce soir à
partir de 19h avec la prise de parole du
premier ministre qui sera donc
accompagné du ministre de la santé quoi
qu'il en soit on a l'impression de se
diriger vers une sortie de crise comme
c'est le cas en espagne ou au royaume
uni et dans le même temps on a ce pass
vaccinale voté par le parlement et qui
pourraient entrer en vigueur dès ce
samedi après examen du conseil
constitutionnel demain c'est vrai que ça
peut paraître paradoxal